we're not playing games we mean business
speaking of the people that that sort of
lied all the way this is just like the
perfect storm of stupidity Lori
Lightfoot who was of course was the
basically communist mayor of Chicago and
destroyed that City what happens uh when
you're a communist politician you get
fired or kicked out and then you end up
at Harvard that's where she's lecturing
now and check this out from the Chicago
Sun Times former Chicago mayor Lori
Lightfoot is officially a college
lecturer at least for a semester as her
graduate level class on health policy
and Leadership
at Harvard University got underway last
week stay tuned guys Lightfoot said she
will use a mock press conference a
simulated community meeting and guest
speakers to teach in part about the
dangers of politicizing a pandemic and
how to interact with the media drawing
on lessons learned from running a city
amid covid 19. I just want to get that
right again because we're going to show
you a clip right now she is running a
graduate level class on health policy
and Leadership and now I would like to
show you a little bit of that Health
policy and Leadership Lightfoot style
Chicago middle middle of covid go we're
not playing games we mean business and
we are going to shut this down one way
or the other the time for educating
people into compliance is over we will
shut you down we will cite you and if we
need to we will arrest you and we will
take you to jail
well I don't think I can say what I'm
thinking because I don't want to get
demonetized today we've been demonetized
twice this week Jeffrey you want to
field this one well she's got a nice
colleague over there with Jacinda ardern
who's enjoying two fellowships at
Harvard so Harvard's become this sort of
sanctuary for the lockdowns today in
Epoch times ironically I wrote a column
called the valorization of the tyrants
and it's all about our Dern's
appointment at Harvard with these two
fellowships the Kennedy School of
government and Joel Roth who is the uh
trust and safety uh uh Czar at Twitter
1.0 uh just got hired by the by the
University of Pennsylvania and uh the
Carnegie Endowment for international
peace with the big fancy scholarship so
this is what's happening to all these
and Brian stelter don't forget Brian
stelter is now teaching media at Harvard
I mean you get fired you ruin a country
and just in this case and yeah you get
you end up at these schools yeah so
maybe uh maybe uh Trump's favorite Mario
Cuomo will be next you know full
professorship you know that'll be I you
know it's it's very strange because it's
a small Junta of these of people out
there that engaged in these
unprecedented policies we've never
pursued lockdowns like this business
closures school closures uh Church
closures uh keeping the big box stores
open shutting down all the small
business ruining everybody's lives
inflating the money implied by a 6.5
trillion dollars and causing rampant
inflation uh worse getting to the point
it's just as bad as it was in 1979.
we've never done anything like this for
you know a basic uh spread of a new
virus nothing like this in in the whole
history of of Modern Life and and and
and we see the results the results are
terrible demoralization loss of
Education loss of health and you know
it's they've obtained the opposite and
yet they're being rewarded for it I mean
Dave it just there's something broken
about the world or something broken
about Academia uh that that this kind of
thing would be happening